you need to start paying attention to  the good guys they'll come up to you  more you need to stop rewarding the bad  boys  you need to teach them  so here's some advice  don't put the goods out there unless  someone earns it  by earn it i mean they have to be  invested in you they have to take you  out on dates  they have to call you  they have to prioritize you  they have to make you feel good maybe  they open the car door for you imagine  that  something right out of  1985. maybe they pay for your dinner  maybe they call you make sure oh hey how  did it go yeah i had a really good time  pick up the phone not a text  not 2022  gentlemanly  they treat you with respect you feel  good about that situation all that needs  to happen before you put the goods out  there